cinco de mayo it just starts saying what
better place to celebrate than dorado
cantina the sponsors of our next segment
and joining us to tell us all about the
festivities at their locations is ceo
ryan claussen and corporate chef john
miranda welcome you guys thank you for
having us again i mean if we're going to
have a cinco de mayo party you got to be
at el dorado cantina right we got
options we have three in the valley we
have one near the strip we have one in
the southwest and we also have one in
tivoli village in summerlin i love it
you're all over the place and of course
we're going to be celebrating with some
margaritas and some mixed drinks right
tell us about the selection that you
guys have because i'm seeing these four
here and i'm like i don't know which one
i would want to choose they are equally
delicious el dorado margarita this is
our cucumber jalapeno margarita mango
margarita and our strawberry mint
margarita oh man and you so it's going
to be a party there of course tell us
what you guys are going to be doing
people will be partying
we have live music we'll have a band
we'll have a dj we have a big stage
built outside
we have a gigantic patio indoor area a
lounge area
we're going to be activated from 11 a.m
until 1 2 in the morning and we'll keep
the party going longer if we have to
well chef john you got to talk to me
about the food because the food at el
dorado is so fantastic tell us about
some of your specialty dishes what you
guys are going to be serving up for the
for the big day sure i mean we have
everything from fajitas burritos
um
anything you could name in mexican
cuisine uh but here we have our taco
platter we have our famous tableside
guac and then our chili's very very uh
popular with us on a scale of one to ten
what's the spiciness factor on this one
because that looks like right my speed i
wanna i wanna have some of this
defensive us i think it's a five
i think it's a thirteen
okay so we've got a little disparity
here though now you mentioned the three
locations can you go over them again and
you're gonna have these the the
festivities at all three locations right
festivities all three um we have a
location near the strip on sammy davis
junior drive uh we have another location
in the southwest off durango and 215 and
then we have our tivoli village location
uh which is in summerlin right off the
right off rampart so after the party's
over it's still there's still a lot to
enjoy over at el dorado you're doing
something for mother's day from what i
understand we are we're going to be
rolling out the red carpet for all the
moms
we're offering free mimosas to all moms
along with some chocolate covered
strawberries we'll have a full selection
of our brunch menu along with our
regular house menu as well so that
starts at 10 a.m and goes till 3 p.m on
sunday it's going to be a really really
fun and uh again great time for
everybody well are you and you're also
doing the fight too right showing the
canelo fight at our southwest location
um it's 50
to reserve a seat um right now we're at
about 75 capacity so there still is some
availability last time we showed canelo
we had a packed house it was amazing
very festive and exciting chef john uh
just one more question about the food
here i mean you're behind it if you
could only order one thing off the menu
what's the
the one item that everyone has to has to
have
oh don't ask me that
no i think the shrimp and childs are
very very popular oh man everything is
so good you have to check them out el
dorado cantina
cinco de mayo mother's day every day it
is a party there and you're gonna love
it thank you guys so much for joining us
i'll send it over to you jillian